watch this clip and tell me if you can
identify two big problems with it
okay so did you catch those problems
there were two biggies the first being
that there was air in that syringe we
never want to inject air into a patient
especially if we're doing an IV
injection because this could lead to an
air embolism therefore we always want to
purge that air from that syringe next
the angle the person is using is all
wrong this is roughly about a 90 degree
angle which is what we would use for an
IM injection or some Sub-Q injections
and this site here is actually not good
for either of those because there's no
significant muscle or fat here so if
this person was trying to inject
intravenously they're doing it at the
wrong angle we would want to do it at
about a 15 to 30 degree angle so we
wouldn't go through the vein and we
would also want to use IV cannulation so
we could easily and safely administer
this medication to the patient